hello are you guys amazing it's good to
be here so we're super excited to be
here with the guys and thought we'd take
some time to share just some fun stories
about what we've learned from mushrooms
fish poop breakfast cereal and what
that's taught us about selling in a
retail retail distribution and to take a
quick step back tell you a very summery
quick summary of our story we started
out of my fraternity kitchen and
actually before that we were sitting in
a lecture of about 200 people her you
could grow mushrooms on coffee waste led
us to then growing some buckets walk
that bucket into Whole Foods got 5,000
bucks from our Chancellor and ended up
giving up Investment Banking and
consulting to instead become full-time
mushroom farmers along the way have now
through an incredible journey alongside
this amazing man
maybe boy and these amazing products
which we're ready to grow ready to eat
products a mushroom farm a water garden
a garden in a can and now organic
breakfast cereal and breakfast Stoppers
that are now sold in over 14,000 grocery
stores around the country and Canada
Australia and Russia as well so yeah
thought we kind of walk you guys through
a handful these products and a handful
the stores you got into and just kind of
the tangible stories of how it actually
happened and to start off we want to
start off with our main account the
first account we ever had which was
Whole Foods and I wanted to go back to
those buckets Alex was talking about so
here we are last semester in college we
had just heard this random fact we had
met up kind of fell in love this idea of
growing food off of waste and planted 10
feet like Ace Hardware paint buckets and
mushrooms in his fraternity kitchen and
is it right before spring break and we
come back from Spring Break and
with moments we'll never forget
and that nine of these buckets are just
totally contaminated nasty more going on
them but one of them like literally that
bucket right there it was the only
bucket that grew this beautiful crop of
oyster mushrooms and by that time we had
no background in food let alone you know
mushrooms remember alex is like a Nikoli
trying those like dude there's no way
I'm trying these monkey drying there's
no way I'm trying them either and so we
were like looking ourselves like what do
we do and what's the best restaurant in
town and it was cheap Panisse is pretty
close by and yeah it did at that point
even know what that meant but we're like
let's take it over there and really walk
that paint bucket of mushrooms into Chez
Panisse and Alice Waters happen to be
there I think we had our you know to
Berkeley shirts on she actually listened
to us for a second and gets her head
chef over ladies hey Callie gonna try
these and you saute his half of them up
and it's like wow she's actually really
good and it was kind of that moment
really
that's my might have something here and
partly we were kind of upset at the fact
that he had taken half of the mushrooms
that we had grown I mean we're like
that's literally the only thing that we
have and but we took that that that
bucket that 5-gallon Ace Hardware bucket
with half as many mushrooms and we just
walked it over to the Berkeley Whole
Foods actually about a mile and a half
away and first produce guy we saw just
went up to the guy and said hey we you
know think we figure out grow mushrooms
on coffee waste and that was actually
the story that I was like that's all
we've got and then he was like his eyes
lit up though and he then calls over his
team leader he grabs a few other people
gets his bucket right puts it in the
middle of the store and then he's like I
will shoot us an email well we took that
same bucket we were like we don't know
if that's actually gonna turn into
anything we took that same bucket walked
it into every single grocery store in
like a 15 mile radius from andronica
every andronicus in Berkeley in Oakland
we went to farmer Joe's we went to
Berkeley bowled at the time there was
only one Berkeley but we walked to
rainbow crush we walked to all these
other grocery stores and craziest thing
is the only retail that actually reached
back out to us was Whole Foods we got
this email as a one-sentence email from
randy to come and he was the regional
coordinator of produce at the time and
he just said this is pretty cool here's
my cell phone and ended up give him a
call this is for my fraternity room and
both just put her on speaker ended up
talking this guy for about 45 minutes
and we like he's like Alex stop talking
somebody's like if you figure this out
he's like I'm gonna blow you up in Whole
Foods he's like this most innovative
I've seen a produce taking coffee
waste growing mushrooms is like I love
it just he's like wait what the hell
were you guys doing before this were
like investment banking and consulting
is like I give that up give that up so
we're like okay and he's like eh I'll
make sure this works out somehow and
turn that that that buyers belief into
into getting a $5,000 grant from our
Chancellor at UC Berkeley and got some
buckets got some you know a few more
racks got an $800 van to be able to
collect coffee waste and started
collecting coffee grounds walked around
different cafes and picked up every
morning with then harvest the mushrooms
sell them at farmer's markets aalam at
the Berkeley whole food stores in
Oakland store and yeah you know so with
Whole Foods - so we started selling
fresh mushrooms this is about six months
after graduated to spend six months
trial and error trying to figure it out
finally figured it out and started going
mushrooms like that and you know I was
at this moment we kind of realized we're
in about 30 Whole Foods just NorCal but
saw an opportunity to kind of start
taking some of our passions and trying
to develop products whether retailers -
and it's one step to go into a store
another step to kind of try to build
that relationship and we had this idea
we're like a lot of people are getting
really excited not just what we're going
but how they grow because there's
mushrooms grow in just ten days and so
we had this idea for this little girl at
home mushroom kit and we decided to go
and present it to Randy who's our NorCal
produce buyer and the first thing
presented him was that bag on the left
and imagine that with a sticker we
printed off of FedEx and this is all we
were in during a meeting talking about
like fresh mushroom production and
demand forecasting and had this thing in
a bag underneath the table like waiting
for the perfect moment to pill up you
know pull it out and as if it was a next
you know Apple iPhone we had like just
so much energy on it so he finally and
in the meeting take this were like Randy
you got something to show you and pull
out this bag unveil this beautiful
mushroom kid and he literally falls out
of his chairs it was disgusting thing
I've ever seen no one's putting a bag of
fungus on their kitchen counter and I
just you know it was this moment where
we kind of realized hey oh is that
really opportunist have one of our
retailers give us like kick in the butt
and what's now become a pillar for us is
design
and we got that from our retail and
start developing this weatherman went
through this crazy journey of design of
how to actually take this content and
make it look good and bring it into
homes and turn that into what is today
our first main poly ethyl go to how
mushroom kits you pop it open and in 10
days again about a pound of fresh
mushrooms right out of the box this one
was unique we put this in in one Berkley
whole food store within three months we
were national with Whole Foods every
single store in the country and at first
very exciting you know two guys had
never never sold a single thing in a
retailer so we thought we had made it
something we're like dude this is sick
like we're in every store it's so easy
and then we got displays a little bit of
like this around the country and and the
same time especially this is about three
and a half four years ago get a call
again from from from all foods around
the country like guys you need to demo
this this isn't selling really what do
you mean but you already bought he's
like yeah we bought it but come and do
some demos dude we're like okay like yes
that's what it takes so it was kind of
realization that there's one thing about
getting in the store but the other ones
about getting it to the consumer and it
was us to working we had an 800 square
foot warehouse still that we somehow
managed to get enough production
nationwide but at the time right away we
said alright cool we'll get a flight
one-way flight out to Washington DC Nick
Hill took the West Coast on LA and we
just demoed as soon as the Whole Foods
would open until we closed and we'd go
from store to store to store we got this
we rented this this car on the East
Coast this purple hideous car was paying
$17 a day this was most is amazing and
we went I went from DC down to the
Research Triangle drove all the way
across the Lena then drove it all the
way back up to Boston New York and then
flew back out right after Christmas to
be able to barely make for the 25th
dinner but I think the reality is I
think it's taking so much real effort
for us to actually start building a
movement around people to be able to say
like hey can actually put this in my
kitchen it was hand selling the crap out
of these it was one consumer at a time
and one grocery store at a time one
produce department of time and now it's
been amazing to even see where I think
about two years ago Walter out there
co-ceo of
foods was like I think Alex and nikka
visited more Whole Foods and some of our
team has and so I was very cool yeah
yeah at least when we started growing
Whole Foods and this is kind jump in our
next retail partner and it you know so
this is a couple years ago we just kind
of built out this whole food
distribution and at that point still
didn't have an office in eight hundred
square foot warehouse in Emeryville and
so we go there plant in the mornings and
then go but Ashley this is the
Emeryville Home Depot and right next to
it is a Starbucks so that was her office
like two years with the Starbucks you
know open it up closed it out and every
morning we're working at that Starbucks
and right across from us is this Home
Depot was beautiful lawn and garden
center were like why do these mushroom
kids have to go in like how do we get
these mushroom gets in that garden
center and after enough thinking and
trying to figure it out we're like let's
just take that same approach we did with
Whole Foods and decide to walk in that
that Emeryville you know Home Depot with
a couple mushroom kits and it was funny
we asked that that stores buyer to
introduce us to his regional buyer and
at that point he's like you guys are two
crazy kids trying to grow mushrooms on
coffee grounds like I can't do that but
he did drop his buyers name and you
wouldn't was he willing introduce us cuz
he didn't want to put you know his name
on the line for two people he didn't
know but he gave us his name and we said
that's all that's all it takes is only
so many variations of that email address
that can be so we tried first name dot
last name you know that every dispersed
initial last initial literally I think
missing 20 things he sent over to one of
them actually came through and just an
incredible response and Tim was like
you're interesting I'm down in San Diego
do you want to meet and Alex jumps on
the next flight down there and and meets
up four times of course yeah those
things of course I'm in town easily and
make the heat up not trying to sound
desperate at all but make that make that
trip happen and but literally that one
email address does 20 attempts turn into
a meaning with Tim and it's just crazy
to see how one meeting one email can
start cultivating a relationship and
actually just this week we're excited
that Home Depot expanded its nationally
into 850 stores nationwide
with displays across the country but
that started off with a arm
goodbye aquaponics aquaponics is a the
second product that we created we create
a mini aquaponics kit and the way we
developed actually was out of just mere
curiosity we were doing farm tours we
ended up doing a farm tour with Whole
Foods in the Midwest we went up to
Milwaukee and visited this farm that was
taking and we had never seen anything
like had any of you heard about
aquaponics oh dang that's a lot it's so
I'll say this was about 2 and 1/2 years
ago three years ago I was even less
people at the time I'd never heard of it
but I went up to Milwaukee saw this and
I was completely blown away it was the
craziest thing you were in the middle of
one of the toughest areas of Milwaukee
and this farmer Will Allen was had
turned this into this most amazing urban
farm they were taking all this fish poop
pumping it up using as a fertilizer
organic fertilizer for the plants up top
so they were growing from lettuce to
basil to cilantro everything and the
craziest part of it all is that that
fish it was actually the fertilizer for
the plants and then the plants were
indirectly cleaning the water bringing
back down for the fish so is this really
cool ecosystem where the fish would feed
the plants plants would clean the water
and the system was using 10 times less
water less energy and nickel I looked at
this and we were like this is the
coolest thing we've ever seen like how
come we had never heard of it we're like
can we create the smallest system ever
and we got a picture from will saying
like there's already a kid out there and
he sent us this picture of something was
like four feet by four feet 500 bucks
and we were like that is not it's not an
aquaponics kit and we spent a big leap
of faith is cuz you know injection
molded plastic product that we'd never
even you know come close to creating a
first one was mushroom farming a
mushroom kit but we went out there leap
of faith and we made a slight mistake in
that we didn't present it to our buyer
to begin with and here we just went at
it went all-in and went back to say show
the prototype to Whole Foods and he said
this time he's like guys I can't launch
this like this is the fish tank go to a
pet store and right
well how do you do that you know so we
we said instead decided to go to
Kickstarter we say we had a community
that was passionate evangelist consumer
through our mushroom kid we had you know
we had such and I think we've been
building such relation by going every
single store all those customers that
bought the mushroom kits and put this up
on Kickstarter we had $100,000 goal
ended up doing $250,000 in 30 days of
pre-orders we took that momentum took it
over to our website another quarter
million dollars so this is half a
million dollars of pre-orders without
even creating the damn thing so we took
that buzz and went back to Petco went
back to Whole Foods went back to
Nordstrom and for the first time ever
those three retailers took this product
on nationwide so we had a national
launch with Whole Foods national launch
with Petco national ons with Nordstrom
and Petco actually put a little fish
coupon inside because obviously Whole
Foods is never going to solve fish or
Nordstrom's not going to sell fish and
we were able to use that coupon for
anybody that bought it anywhere in the
country they could go to Petco
and but so here you are you know
launching into into all these retailers
and I think this is a lesson one we
though right away was just kind of still
like getting caught up in that momentum
how to say no to buyers - and take the
time you need to take it in this case we
actually ended up rushing our launch
interview tailors with this packaging at
the time we thought it looked gorgeous
we're like it's symbolic its artistic it
hits the stores and we're like people
have no clue what this is it's a big red
fish on the you know and it's like dark
little looking tank and wasn't moving
wasn't selling or like crop we just
totally bombed this packaging because
all the Sun developing a product now we
can't communicate in stores and and then
actually having to do I can urge in
rebranding of this packaging and all
that goodwill we had built up with
stores now we're here we are calling
this produce buyers saying can you guys
please take these off this - off the
store off the ground and actually
putting these new ones in and it was
just this crazy learning curve of like
how to bill momentum at the same time
have enough kind of forward - to say no
and take the time you need to take to
launch it right and ended up redesigning
it to what it is today a much more like
bright vibrant colorful packaging that
actually stands out and luckily I
learned that lesson with Kickstarter and
Whole Foods who was really flexible with
us and learned it in time to be able to
do it right in Costco but that was a
it's learning for us about this balance
of retail of building momentum
you're taking your time dear right
because you can make one mistake it can
it can put you out yeah and as we grew
distribution and grew partnerships too
you know we're in a few thousand
retailers at the time but more
importantly we were starting to build I
think just genuine authentic
relationships with our buyers directly
and you know I think we started to have
a voice and care about very particular
things and we you know develop pillars
to what we wanted back to loosest and
for on the on the community out in the
world and one of the most important
things there is you know we really
started taking big bets with our
retailers and we approached Whole Foods
and Costco and Amazon in particular and
Whole Foods from just the inspiration of
how to grow food you know much more
sustainable and just better way for the
for society and had an opportunity to
meet with the executive vice president
of purchasing and sat down with them
with the head of produce head of grocery
and the first thing he said is alright
guys go and visit some more farms learn
more about food because you guys don't
really know that much yet and we said
okay so we took we took the opportunity
go with local foragers all around the
country we ended up going to farms from
Hawaii to Chicago to New York one of
those was this top right that is
actually believe it or not that is an
avocado it over a thousand varieties of
avocados in Hawaii and we're used to
eating one variety mostly for the most
part here at Hass avocado and through
learning about heirloom varieties just
became more and more curious more
passionate about just how food used to
be grown in the past how our
grandparents used to eat how they used
to cook and all that visited you know
saw totally different kinds of bananas
these little baby bananas that are huge
in India huge in Latin America but you
never see them in a grocery store here
unless you go to an ethnic market and
all that led us to a wheat farm and that
wheat farm blew our minds on a season
well this moment sir you visit this farm
and you see something you're eating
every single day probably since the day
you're born almost and we quickly
realize like we had no clue how we
actually grew or our turning like all
this food around us even asked us talk
of we turned into a cracker of bread a
cookie we couldn't tell you we're like
that's insane and then B we started
learning all this crazy stuff what
happens to wheat based on industrial
milling system all the stuff has taken
out of wheat all the nutrients the bran
the germ the endosperm is broken up and
we star
asking yourselves like how else did
wheat used to grow and how else did it
used to be milled and it led us down
this this incredible exploration of the
last year of visiting all these
different like ancient milling practices
and kind of started honing in this
really cool practice with stone milling
grains where you know 100 pounds of
wheat goes into a mill and 100 pounds of
flour comes out nothing's added or
removed or fortified or broken apart
it's just it's really pure you know
grain and really pure flour with like
how can we bring this back to more
people today and bring it back to our
generation something we were doing
hundred years ago and we started looking
at all these different categories around
stores like where are grains used today
whereas we used today and started really
focusing in on this aisle and we're like
here's this monstrosity of an aisle
right a hundred-year-old category 100
years old 10 billion dollar industry and
it has been any innovation from
packaging to ingredients to branding
it's either these really brown boring
granola boxes or these bright pink you
know deserts dressed up as a health food
and we're like can we bring this
innovation to it and ended up working
really hard with last few months to kind
of undo this category like alex is
saying taking it back to to how it used
to be done and developed for the first
time the first u.s. grown 100%
stone-ground breakfast cereal made with
just three ingredients and packaging it
in an entirely new form factor and
putting that actually brand new Organic
stone-ground flakes which we launched
exactly one month ago now alongside a
whole new kind of line of convenience
customization to the entire category of
these breakfast toppers and it's just
been this incredible journey first of
how do we start code developing these
products alongside of our partners
actually and it's not just really
interesting learnings this is literally
over the last five weeks this is all
happening as we speak so people still a
lot of people still think we're nuts
we're crazy for going from mushroom
farming of fish poo farming to now we
and cereal making and you know through
that we've you know as I briefly
mentioned we developed this alongside
Whole Foods from the learning of how
food grew to wheat farming but we worked
with Costco at the same time and it was
a GMM of Costco for we worked I mean
this is a nine month in the process and
the making we worked with Amazon because
one of the problems is they're losing so
much money delivering this to the home
because a cereal box has 40 perfor t to
50% air so you're shipping half of the
the cereal or selling
being shipped with just air so worked on
having for the first time it's 100%
recyclable box but it's also 90 percent
fill rates so you can use 25 percent
less packaging as well but one of the
challenges we had is two weeks before
we're hitting stores the AGM Emma cast
go ends are retiring and we're like okay
whatever we're going to you know
continue to this momento minute
fortunately the momentum wasn't fully
there they had no idea what was
happening and we had two weeks to
somehow get her excited about something
we had worked on for almost you know 910
almost a year with and what we did snow
and what we did know ahead of time is
one of our strengths has been demoing we
learned it firsthand and we said listen
like has anybody demoed cereal in in
Costco and they're like no we've been
selling it for you know for 20 years
here nobody's ever come in and demo like
done like lettuce demo crap out of that
thing we'll go out there make sure we
prove in its exactly what's happening
today and what we've done in the last
five weeks we're the number one selling
organic cereal and Costco nationwide
we're selling right now in the Bay Area
but thank you
just had that humongous honor meeting
with the daughter of the founder of
Costco in San Diego two weeks ago we're
going to be launching down in San Diego
Colorado Arizona and Los Angeles regions
of Costco and it all has been just off
trying to find a key opportunity for us
was being able to just demo the darn
thing and I will say through that it's
led us to Whole Foods also being a key
partner Walter Robb actually putting it
up on stage with hundreds of people
there saying that this does cereal could
actually change the game with three
goliaths post Kellogg's GM running the
show they own 90% of this ten billion
dollar industry and it's pretty amazing
to see a support and you know I we
talked about some successes I got we
can't leave this stage without talking
about a lot of failures one of those is
Safeway we've been trying in and out we
had opportunities with the floral buyer
was super excited launched just
completely flopped we tried demoing
didn't work and went back to our roots
and a little bit you know in some way we
went back we had cold email the Home
Depot buyer said hey how about it's cold
email the president this time we'll see
what happens and got a chance and this
is still in the making we still have not
a real strong relation with Safeway but
at least they gave us one more
opportunity and we're now working with
the buyer for produce and looking to see
if we can do it better we took that same
we've done it with Kroger and and we're
now just met with the Kroger buyer last
week we're gonna be launching at 800
Kroger's in October we've called imelda
the CEO we said hey this is what we're
doing we can't wait to be able to
partner with you and wrote a really nice
note back and ultimately it's just at
the other day has just turned into how
do we create products that were so
passionate about and get it out to
everybody try to find advocates in every
corner and if you lose an advocate one
way just keep on swinging and that's a
you know I guess to wrap up on this
whole talk right now I kind of think if
there's one thing I leave you know I
think that we've learned it's that
number one of all this stuff reaching
out finding advocates finding customers
doesn't really matter if you don't stay
true to what you believe and that took
us a long time to kind of really find
that and hone in on it and I think now
we feel more clear than ever and for us
that's developing products that are you
know well designed with a kid focus and
a real big focus of sustainability and
you know people ask us how could you
launch a mushroom kit a fish tank and
now breakfast to you and I think for us
it's because that underlying theme we've
stayed true doing and that's the
lesson learned is staying true to
yourself and for us it's connecting
families back to their food and
simplifying it undoing it through its
really fun design lens and you know at
the end of the day though there's
there's this you know I think we step
back and is one thing I want to leave
you guys with it's the retail and retail
distribution isn't magic there's no
secret sauce it's it's a lot of hard
work it's it's like Alex said you got to
keep on swinging and finding those
advocates and it's a little bit of luck
and at the end of the day it's I think
we always challenge ourselves whether
it's let's keep on swinging keep on
outreaching find those partners but then
once you find them latch on like hell
and don't let go and keep on trying to
co-develop boy them and see what you can
do together and I think we're learning
firsthand right now that that by going
deeper with this partnerships too can
lead to some really incredible things
and we're super excited for this next
four years I had being able to take this
branding span from what started off as
an urban mushroom farm and really trying
to ask yourself this question like what
would Kraft Foods look like it was
invented today by our AG by Millennials
and its focus on sustainability
transparency and it sounds like a really
big question but we think as long as we
find those partners and do it together
we can hopefully do something pretty
exciting and thank you guys for letting
to share this story so appreciate it
great thanks guys
if you have any questions for them come
on down hi guys thank you so much for
the talk I really enjoyed it
my question is kind of purposefully
broad so please feel free to answer it
and however you like I'm curious how you
look back on this journey that you've
been on and obviously what strikes me
most is that you have such a passion for
this and that that passion is obviously
grown right you found out about things
that you never thought you would be
finding out before like a fascination
with flour for example right your
investment Baker selves of the past
probably would have thought you were
crazy I'm sure being like you're going
to be fascinated in five years about how
flour is made but obviously at the same
time you know growing these mushroom
kids there was a fascination that you
guys had with that and I'm just curious
how you think about or how you see
looking back what that like real
fascination was and how you were able to
cultivate it because I think it's
something similar to what the Pandora
founder was talking about before and
like that magic that really can't be you
know like bought or like gotten other
than just by really feeling it
I could just bring up one one thing
which we we talked about a little bit
but it's just curiosity I would say is
at the core to a lot of these things and
curiosity and our you know curiosity in
Bangka I love finance I I had a true
genuine interest in in and I think you
know Nick Hill has had amazing
experience himself building different
things in college and you know basic
valedictorian of our Business School
himself through just putting himself out
there and asking the questions and I
think now as we continue to grow the big
challenge and the big question we're
always asking our team is continuing to
be curious and I think that leads to so
many things
and that's alternate what's led to the
enemy even our brand just quick build
off of that it's like we really try to
focus our brand not on this idea
especially the food words so personal
saying what's right or wrong about food
because to be friendly we're not smart
enough to know that I think it's such a
complicated answer
we're like Happy's build a brand that's
not around teaching what's right or
wrong it's just about trying to get
people curious to ask that question
themselves like where's this come from
and I think it's not off but I think it
started off because when you so little
about food we is almost like we didn't
know that going into but we do still
about food starting all we can do is ask
questions and now students it's a big
part of our brain it's just like we got
to make sure we're just focusing on
education but on curiosity thank you so
in the interest of time we'll take just
these three hey guys I really like your
story
um this is kind of like a question and
also like a recommendation because again
I really liked her as a story and like
it really like I was able to connect
with it so I wanted to ask are you guys
interested in like potentially reaching
out your Food Network and going on
what's it called food fortunes it's like
Shark Tank but for food network sure I'd
love to happen to share your story I
guess use it or not yeah sounds awesome
okay do you guys like how many plans
that you'd like to share with the crowd
like what like you know food or toys
wait what to like get on to food
fortunes on Food Network are we
auditioning now I mean that is really
cool
what is it oh that sounds like an
awesome it's a question and a
recommendation and the question is is do
we want yes absolutely
like have you guys considered it and
like are there any plans and if there
are any plans I'd love to hear them
Oh to go on yeah to kind of like have
like your I've never heard of the show
that sounds awesome
yeah look at your food fortunes on Food
Network's food for six fortunes yeah
it's like Shark Tank okay yeah
cool thank you that's good fortunes um
so it sounds like you've had a few
products where you've just kind of gone
out there and done it and you've
launched with you know more and less
successful designs but have you found
any more lightweight ways to test
whether it's design ideas or product
ideas in the offline market rather than
just kind of going out and seeing if it
sells or not because offline markets
meaning I just online you can do a kind
of test see if anyone's you know
clicking or having general pickup
interest very quickly versus offline
you're just waiting for results to come
in terms of sales have you found any so
one way I mean we I could talk about me
in terms of definitely it's very
important to us and key I think the
water garden is a really cool example of
putting on a Kickstarter we had no idea
we ourselves weren't even sure we could
actually launch this thing if there's a
demand for it there was a gut feeling
put it out there and that was a really
cool way in which we almost you know
very much soft launch it where we had
the pre-orders before we been creating
it even with a serial you know we've
gone through so many iterations on taste
and flavor to get to where it is today
so the cool thing is like even working
with our partners were able to go into
demos and stores we're demoing at other
products but have these like different
variations of cereal and just four
months in advance get like taste
profiles get gut checks from customers
like hey do you like this blind taste
test so we've tried to find waste like
leverage the community built with other
products to now kind of get that gut
check earlier because I think even now a
larger swing as we take that's the more
risk too so like we launched a cereal
first in the cost going like with the
water gun we launched on Kickstarter
launching this thing first in the
costume is we couldn't mess up we messed
up we were out of business so we had to
kind of feel really confident about it
beforehand but answers your question hey
so I was really interested in learning a
little bit more about the manufacturing
process I don't think you guys touched
on that's uh yeah so yeah two quick
assets cloud has something so so I think
but we're so passionate about so we
started off actually quick story in
terms of one less in terms of finding
things you're really good at so we
started company everything ourselves you
wake up at literally the morning collect
coffee grounds come back
anthem uh shrooms harvest um sell um do
repeat rinse and repeat for you know
literally a year and a half and but
through that way we kind of realize one
thing which is that we sucked
growing mushrooms to be frank with you
we're not very good at it and you know
at one summer we kind of I think
overheated that was the mushroom kids
could we did know how to mess with the
fluctuation summer heat just like all
these learning curves and along the way
with this mushroom farm up in Sebastopol
gourmet mushrooms first guys thirty
years ago to grow gourmet mushrooms in
North America and they were mentoring us
for a while and finally we got to the
scale they were like hey it might make
sense for us to try to incubate these
for you and at first we were really
hesitant because that was our baby we
were farmers we were producing this
every single day ourselves were hands-on
with it we knew we knew we were doing
and finally we're convinced to let them
to try some amateur growing up and the
first batch came back quality
consistency was just like night and day
for anything we were able to do and it
was kind of like that lesson learned of
like the spine partners who are better
at things than we are and let them do it
and after seeing a success of like
finding a partner to grow our mushrooms
we've taken that not all our products
and but the key there is like finding
the right partners you really believe in
because end of the day that's everything
you have is a quality of that product
and so with the water garden is last
story you know we had it's an acrylic
injection molded item and we had try to
source all these different manufacturers
and 95% of manufactures but I kind of
stuff for overseas and spend a lot of
time trying to find can we find one here
locally and actually found a partner in
Union City when the few injection molder
'he's called Jacko who's been just an
incredible partner so that product is
actually like a hundred percent us-made
NorCal made thing for an injection
molded plastic piece which is pretty
rare but it's become so cordless like
the spine partners we can visit we know
and we know who's making it for us cool
thanks thanks guys thank you because